so there were sadly suspicions
that there may have been police officers
who either stood aside or even helped
the trump rioters on january 6th
and sadly it appears that this is true
we've now learned that
several members of the united states
capitol police have been
suspended according to acting capital
police chief
yogananda pittman earlier yesterday
congressman tim ryan
a former guest on this program said that
two officers had been suspended
one officer took a selfie with one of
the violent insurrectionists another
gave them
a tour of the capitol building according
to congressman ryan
tim ryan also saying that there are 10
to 15
ongoing investigations into officer
conduct
during the insurrection this was at a
press conference given yesterday by tim
ryan
ryan also indicated that a third
individual has been arrested but said
it's not
currently clear if they're a member of
the capitol police
or the national guard and this is um
i mean listen there's a few different
things that have to be talked about here
first of all
we were cautious when the theory started
that this was a plot and that capitol
police
in advance were planning to
usher in protesters and i said as those
theories started to
be presented let's be careful about that
because we don't have evidence of that
yet when we saw
you know a 15-second video of police
clearing some barricades uh and that was
pointed to as evidence of a conspiracy
involving the capitol police i said we
we have to be careful because
anybody who knows about crowd control
knows that once you know
you're you are overwhelmed and your
physical barriers will
will not hold you do move the physical
barriers to avoid
others and yourself getting hurt and
trampled by the barriers themselves and
so i i urged caution
and indeed what we know listen i think
one of the important things is
if your view on police is radically
different
today than it was around the george
floyd protests
then you should question whether your
view is tuned to reality
during the george floyd protests my view
was that based on everything i knew
most police officers are doing their
jobs to the best of their abilities
and most police officers are becoming
officers
generally speaking for the right reasons
because they want to
protect their communities uh do do
something that's good for their
communities
and there are a lot there are too many
bad actors
that slip through the cracks due to lack
of systems that prevent them from doing
so and so when you're talking about an
apparatus as large as law enforcement
there's no doubt that there will be
horrible people in a group
uh and a bad apple can spoil the bunch
so it's not a surprise that now we are
starting to see
two three people suspended a dozen under
investigation i'm
sure that there are more than two
officers involved last week
and potentially even even military folks
as well the investigations are ongoing
that behaved absolutely atrociously
um eventually there should be firings
and not suspensions
but i think it's also important that you
know when
when we jump into the conspiracy
theories or when we start making the
claims that aren't based in fact
we become just as bad as them and
there's no reason to do it eventually
the truth is going to
going to come out the suspensions are
happening the arrests of the rioters are
happening and it's all happening and
remember there are also people in law
enforcement
who acted heroically last week eugene
goodman
is a capital police officer who is
rightly being hailed
as a hero who realized what was going on
realized that the armed
that the violent insurrectionist some of
whom we suspect were armed
were getting into the direction of the
senate chamber in which there were
senators
and eugene goodman lured these rioters
in the opposite direction eugene goodman
made himself a decoy
so let's take this a step at a time
yes investigations is anyone surprised
that
some when you look at the percentage of
of law enforcement that voted trump
of course in that there are going to be
some people that are
carried away by what they love to see
there were people in law enforcement who
loved what happened last week some even
participated off duty
so of course we're seeing this so the
investigations must continue
we need attention to be devoted to
investigating supervisors and leadership
to figure out what happened and that
means both
supervisors and leadership who ignored
the signs that were there that this was
likely or probable to happen
um and that needs to be investigated as
well the difficult part
is that for every two that actually
helped in a way
that warrants a suspension like the two
that have been suspended so far
there were a bunch that sort of were
okay with it and kind of looked the
other way
and it wasn't criminally negligent but
it's still very problematic and that is
much more difficult
to weed out and to deal with but again
most of the people on duty were just
doing their jobs
and they effectively ended up abandoned
by management and colleagues
anyone that watches the videos can tell
that a vast majority of the police on
scene
were doing their jobs and they were
putting themselves in harm's way and
very importantly
any officer that was involved in any way
must be fired they must lose pension
progress
that they've made and it must be taken
extraordinarily seriously you're not
going to change political views by doing
this i understand that
if you're a trumpist and you get fired
because of your role in the riots
uh trump is police officer you don't all
of a sudden become a progressive i
understand that it would be naive to
think so
but the point is much like the point i
made about the need to
find and arrest and charge and throw the
book at the rioters themselves
which is that and we're going to talk
momentarily about the risk of more of
these riots coming up in the next week
eight days
if the punishments aren't severe they
will be encouraged
to do it again and that's the biggest
risk and it seems that it is sadly going
to happen
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee they're having a huge
short lasting black friday sale
right now when you use my link which
gives you up to fifty percent off
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic fair trade
single origin arabica coffee with
both lions maine and chaga mushrooms
chaga mushrooms have actually been shown
to have potential
in supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
lately it tastes
nothing like mushrooms it just tastes
like delicious coffee
it's really easy on the stomach doesn't
give you a jittery feeling or a midday
crash
and if you try it yourself you will see
why they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get all your money back because
they stand behind their product
you really have nothing to lose by
giving it a try their incredible black
friday sale is offering you up to 50
off plus an additional 10 off sale items
but only when you go to four sigmatic
dot com slash
pacman the link is right underneath this
video